You
Hello
How's it going? It's an early morning for madam and when I say early it's just 10 a.m
which is the time that
normal people have already gotten up, but you know
Oh
Yeah, you can't see it in my brand new reaction to this game. Yep. Mm-hmm
It's I can't wait. It's gonna be so fun. I've never played this game before
Can't wait can't wait
Turn that BGM down just a smidge in it
How are you guys doing? I
Have Fia on my lap and she's rolling around. What do you do in lady? Oh, she's leaving now, huh?
But it was fun snuggling with you. I was hoping to get some purrs on the microphone. I
Have early let me just wake up
Grab Russian put a little little makeup I
Know some of my Euro viewers are probably pretty happy. I'm I'm this early
Good morning, European viewers
Yes, this is a European. I'm speaking European. This is my European language
You missed the last hour of stream yesterday we didn't stream yesterday, so I don't know what you're talking about
We're playing the first the first game
Boomi is running laps
You probably can hear him
My voice is a little eh today, so I'm going to probably just let the voice actors do their thing for this
game
Uh
There's a second game. Yeah, the re-up is the second game
Um, yeah, we did in a stream yesterday. I'm so sorry. I canceled stream yesterday guys
I just I'm making it up for you by doing two streams today
You get two count them two streams today. Can you believe it?
You get um
You get the Stanley parable and you get class of 09
How's their 56 year old streamer?
Uh, you know, I was awake at 6 a.m.
And then I was like just like how old people do
Um, and then I got some stuff done
And I went like right before I started stream
I went downstairs to take out the trash and the freaking maintenance guys are in my hallway again
And um, and they were just staring at me and I'm like, uh, and I like I probably
I usually don't
like
wear like wearing hyper revealing clothing
But I was super lazy and I was just wearing some like pajama booty shorts and a sweatshirt and no bras
And then I'm just like carrying a shit ton of trash
In my recycling and then they just stare at me and I'm like, I hate it here
And then I just walk past them into the elevator
For those who don't know, um
For those who don't know, uh the other day
The maintenance guys came into my apartment because they thought I wasn't home. I didn't respond
I had headphones on and I had some fun toys and stuff everywhere
And a hanger on my door that says do not disturb my master
So, uh, I and then they left and I then I realized oh I had stuff out
Awkward
Yeah, they were just changing filters and checking my hot water
I'm almost at 4k subs. I know it's crazy. I'm so thankful for that. Why am I bigger?
Um
I'm just getting bigger
Uh as for the 16k on twitter, it's kind of on my alt account
It's kind of daunting actually and I almost don't like it because one I don't like
I liked having just like a small group of you
Hear my rambles and also my naughty naughty stuff
And then two they're probably mostly bots and not genuine like the sex bots from me saying, um
uh porn
Because like the algorithm's been really liking that word so
But I
I hope you guys enjoyed the feat. I think my favorite reaction
To the feat
pick for 16k
was um
Your alt was promoted on my timeline before
I had at you know, it's just this how it be
my favorite
thing was this like
I thought she was brown
She's not dark enough
Kind of like I said I was mixed
I'm very light-skinned. I haven't been outside since the winter
But when I tan I tan like a mother
And I'm like I've only been fighting with this identity crisis my entire life. Now people on the internet are saying I'm not brown enough
And then some people in my maros are like, oh my caramel queen
It's always funny
to me when people
uh
fetishize my skin tone by comparing me to food
That's like always been a thing
like
growing up for me
like, uh caramel, uh milk chocolate, uh
peanut butter like
on my eye
I think maybe y'all have a more fetish, but
I'm like, mm milky way. Mm mocha. Uh my snickers queen. I'm just I'm just
food
4 chain traffic slowed down for half an hour half you post anything
Really? That is hilarious. Um, don't steal it. Yeah, I love don't steal it. She though. Um
Uh
You do be looking delicious. Yeah, I got I got my toes done. Um, I won't lie to you
That's like a picture from like a month ago
Because I was preemptively taking photos just as like for like, um
Possible patreon stuff and fansy stuff
If I decide
You brown surprisingly
Honestly, I remember my mom
Uh
She said
When I was bored like my parents were expecting me to be dark
But I've also like lightened over
As I've grown up like I was very very dark skin when I was young and then randomly
I guess my years of being a neat and not seeing the sun just took away my melanin
Chat would you do it for a sheebie snack?
Oh
But yeah, if you have to go to work or you have stuff to do you can have me in the background
You can just you know, we're just hanging out. We're just we're just chilling this morning. Um
I'll probably have a little bit more energy for the the stanley parable stream. I just wanted to make up for you
Know the lack of stream
Yesterday it was so crazy all this stuff happened and I couldn't stream
um, but uh
Jokes on you. This is my off-riding. Oh good for you. Thank you. Thank you. I think you're great
Thank you. I guess
Weird weird wording, but okay, but um guys. I don't want to make
my uh, my flesh roommate
A major point of discussion to be honest with you
um
So just enjoy me sheebie
Forget rtx sheebie
okay
so
Anyways, uh, I should probably eat something
I'm actually okay today despite dying after eating spicy food yesterday
I'm actually okay. I might um
Throw a sandwich that I got that you guys didn't know about that I got yesterday in my hair fryer so that um
Um
So that uh, I can finish the half of that sandwich
I like shapes with all flavors color sizes flesh roommate. Are you talking about? Yeah the cats
I had I
I had to um
I like I'm really mad at my cats because
They have three litter boxes because you should have a litter box for each cat. Okay
And they only like to use one of those litter boxes and I don't get it. I'm like
So I'm just like it takes me like 15 minutes to scoop one litter box and then the rest are like super fast
Uh going to try it end it all on that by at least by yeah, maybe at this point
I'm sorry. Sometimes I'll get notifications on my phone
For like people who like my tweets and stuff and some of you have the most out-of-pocket usernames that I just
I just can't fathom I
Did we're not gonna talk about my cats shits. Why is chat so poor today?
Hello vtuber v connoisseur. Where's my rating bro? Where's my rating? Did you post it?
Um
Your cat's like but but he's for you for me. Uh
I meant I like you for you. You're good boomi. What are you doing big man?
But uh, yeah, eventually for like monetization stream. I'm thinking that because somebody set me a snack box of
Japanese snacks, so I'm gonna do a thigh and hand well mostly a
Well, I'll kind of be like a neck down cam
in cosplay of sheebie
um
And then I'll have like my cat's bed will probably be off to the side so you might see them
Um, I really I've had some Japanese snacks before
So I'm excited to like eat them again because I can't get them often
Well the box it's it's actually sealed. I've actually demonstrated a lot of self control to not eat the Sakura box
like
Oh
I'm tempted to add like another sort of
um
Snack box to my stream I to be I just need to go grocery shopping like
I only grabbed a couple of things when I went out to get some booze and stuff for um the drunk stream
Excuse me
but um
What the heck is all over my desk?
um
So like I'm like I also I was checking my mail today and I was I got a hello fresh offer and I'm like
You know, I'm so busy
I might just do like the hello fresh stuff and then we can have like cooking streams
So I'm excited
I'm sorry
Mom just took somebody out. I was just begging to be stuck
Don't spam chat with your cringe behavior
I don't it is not does not get rewarded
Throne snack box subscription one
Yeah, I'm like
I added some cat trees to my uh throne for the kitty cats because they I only have um
Like these two and they just fight there's like one they really love and they fight over
I also want to get one that's a little bit lower for rena because rena's 14 years old and I don't want her hurting herself jumping up
although
When I came back from
Dropping off like throwing away my trash
Um, I come back in and all my cats are just sitting on the counter staring at me
and I'm just like
Sorry, did I interrupt some sort of cat meeting like what just happened?
Um
But yeah, I
It's like go back to me randomly blowing up on
um
Twitter I
I'm still going to treat it as an alt like it's not gonna be my main
so you're still gonna get like the spicy whatever's and the um
My rambling and silly stuff and then my main will continue to be
just a little bit
More professional, but I still be my goofy self
But yeah, I generally just don't like it. So I'm like trying to funnel the attention to the other girls
I'm feeling very strawny like or I'm like, uh, she's like
Support my daughters. I'm like support my gen mates. Please. I don't want the attention
I don't
I'm like, okay, cool. I'll probably get like a thousand followers after playing with the algorithm. No
um
Yeah, mercy me and mercy. We're both freaking out on discord. We're just like, oh
I am not the face of healer that is
Incorrect. I do not want to be the face of healer. That is no, that's all of us. I was gonna say it was strawny. It's all of us
um
Rambling's the best part. Well, no, it's because I
I
Smartly retweeted all the spicy stuff. So when people saw that my viral tweet that I think has like
8k or 16k likes first of all, what the hell? Um
They I was like so they went on my they would go to my page and so they would see all that stuff
And they're like, oh, she actually does what she says. Let me follow
And then I also retreated a bunch of the girl stuff
So they would also get the attention like the algorithm is so weird like what I remember when
We first debuted randomly as Zara's
Um post blew up of her like showing off her voluptuous and delicious body
Um, so like the the algorithm it works in mysterious ways
It's not nice. It's just like I
I want them to succeed
So I am also going to just like strawny do everything in my power to
help them succeed and
I don't even measure success by the numbers. It's really just how people react to me
But I know other people do
sometimes
I got 14 likes gross
So
Like if if it was anybody like if it was one of the other girls this happened to like imi or mercy or azura
Or icy
Or strawny we would all have done the same thing and try to lift each other up
And I know like we we will continue to do so because I we all want each other to be great because we know
We have the potential to be amazing in the vtuber sphere, but um
Yeah, I just think it probably left its intended audience because I don't
I don't wreck it like I don't see any vtuber fans
Following me and I'm like god damn it like and my whole timeline is just normy shit
You saw ic's cute outfit pic. Oh hell. Yeah, I did. She's so adorable
You don't even know how cute ic is. She's literally so cute
Like she's so shown me more outfits and the other girl's more outfits that she likes to wear and I'm like
Oh my god, I just wanted to stick you in my pocket and carry you around like the little small b and you are
She's supposed to be the mesugaki or kusa gaki, but she's just my little princess gaki
That's all I gotta say
What to each breach confinement it did oh you're a vtuber, but like yeah, I don't know
What does a vtuber fan look like? I think maybe I'm just used to following other vtubers. Um
I I remember when I first in another in another realm in another life when I worked at a temple as a priestess. Um
I uh, I think my my
My
viewer base was actually mostly other vtubers. I think so I'm just not used to having like actual
People who like vtubers watch me
So
We're 100 kilograms to use those trail of slime at what?
So you're actually making your nsf, but it's not like it's not like my
My sheevy cotton bomb account is my main like that is
The nsfw is my all and yeah, it's bigger, but it's
you know
I just I don't want all that shit clogging up the average person's feed
um
but uh
Vtuber fans of anime profile pictures cordon
Yeah, that's pretty accurate. Um
But yeah, please if you have discovered me through my alt account on twitter, please consider
I'm looking in my description
In checking out the girls. Um, because they are cooler than I am
And they're better at sticking to kayfabe
Uh, I'm just uh, your dorky girl fell dumb
Uh
Put put some your goofy ah humor on me. Well, I do put some my goofy ah humor
Where are the gorillas? They're right here, baby girl. Um, all the veeler girls are amazing. Yeah
that seems to uh be the consensus which I'm
happy for like
I know sometimes like I know strawnee's intention was to get someone of every flavor like you would like one person at least out of all of us
but
I definitely like when we all finally got into chat together and we all got on discord. We all did like our mock debuts. I'm like, oh
they
They the hoes going love this they're fucking gonna love us because we're all amazing
I know
She failed. I like all six. I know it's great. I think we're all just like
Very different and but very alike and I can't wait. Um for when we do more collabs and stuff
I know we have a collab coming up very soon
So i'm very excited
And then I think hold on. Let me look at my schedule. I can't remember
Well, this is too small for me to read. Um
I got strawnee says he's eating sweets from around the world and she got talkies
Okay, oh yes
Oh, yeah, it's all coming together
I
Also need to like set up some collabs of people because I want to collab with dempa. I want to collab with nori
I want to collab with chai
Um, there's a lot of uh vnu girls. I want to collab with I want to collab with the the you may plus girls
Which would be really fun
Uh
Yeah, I just like I just want to make friends
I only
I only have two
Rtx friends
And I haven't seen them in like a month
I need to go outside
Oh chai is really oh, I love chai. She is my my my one and only
Her and nori are my baby girls. We need I need to play overcooked with them again
Oh my god, boomie. What are you doing?
Try to watch all the debuts from the gen big mistake. Literally was a zombie for the day. Curse my time. So oh watch the vods
Watch the vods my dear
only
Making friends in an adult impossible. I know like um, it's like
All right
It like I they were my friends from work too
Like I don't know how to make friends outside of that like do I
Go to a mall and be like who wants to be my friend?
So I'm kind of like because I don't have any fucking hobbies that'll introduce me to new people like oh
Uh, yes, I am an equestrian with my riding crop. Ho, ho, ho. Oh wait, that's not the
Right toggle with my riding crop
And uh, I I meet a lot of other equestrians while riding. Yes, uh, but
Hey
But um
Bro, what are you doing?
Boomie, are you okay? You scared the shit out of me
No, so I I'm fine
My um, so I was feeding my cats wet food this morning. So I put them all on their stainless steel bowls
And boomie decided to zoomie and run over one and it flew across the room. So give me one second to go get that
Yeah, it's okay
It's just your brother being stupid
Dude, where the fuck did the bowl go?
Boomie, how did you throw it? He threw it across
But we're like legit across the room
Where are you running with this in your mouth? Boomie's a big cat. So I want to put a pass up for running with this Google
Why did my tv turn on awkward but I don't know how that happened
Um
Classic cat behavior. Yeah
There are still nerdy hobbies to do as adult to find new friends. Yeah, like me too being
This is my hobby
I remember when I was putting together my db sides, they were like
Oh, um
so what do you do for hobbies and like the person who uh, the the graphic artists that was helping me, um
Put the stuff together and I'm like
V to be
I don't know. I fucking read like I'm boring as fuck. How did I get here? Why do they hire me?
Love the cat action on your streams girlfriend goes to see what the cats are doing ASMR
What the fuck? I just heard a noise. Is someone breaking in? Oh, no, it's my cats
Oh, sorry, I'm drinking tea. It's called throat coat
wink um
But like it's good for throat issues
Because I'm a major fucking yapper. It's been 30 minutes as per usual
and I still haven't started the game and um
But it has licorice root in it and I hate the taste of licorice. Hi, Selma
Oh, yeah, throat coats the bomb. I also have some Ricola next to me
Okay, I also I I'm pretty sure I fixed text to speech in my alerts
um for
Whatchamacallit
uh stream elements
So I should be able to fucking hear what you guys say when you donate
Okay, let me
Meow meow oh fuck
Wow, she's starting the game everybody
She's starting the game. I eated my um
What's it called my overlay because it just bothers the crap out of me sometimes
What's the bubble that I can't fit text into?
Wait, are you tallian?
Hey, I worked. Thank you
Can you hear me? I've been trapped here for oh it didn't fucking work. What the hell
It does my voice line, but it doesn't do the
But it doesn't do the texas speech want the hell
Can you hear me
Hold on. Let me see if I can fix that
It's not a sheebie stream without scuff. Don't forget
Finally I can text to speech the vtuber about being a boy failure midstream
Sorry
Okay, that's good texas speech settings on is it and
Hold on I need checks discord because managers send us a message about all of us to set it up
And I didn't listen
Where's the fuck is it I'll take you along for me to scroll through
You
Minimum amount to toggle text to speech zero
Oh
This isn't just beautiful music
It's actually like really good piano
It should only be a delay of one second
Okay, sorry I can't see chat
Hey, at least I'll be able to see let me get wait. Why am I blushing?
Don't look don't mind me blushing
I wish I could play piano. I've been told I have very long fingers to play piano
Oh
Oh, you know what I'm excited for today I see is ASMR. Oh boy
She's gonna be so damn cute and I'm not gonna be able to control myself. That sounds weird. Um
But I can't wait I'm gonna rate into her. I'm only gonna be streaming for like two hours
Are we that cute you make me make you but no, um, sorry don't don't don't don't get it twisted
Remember you're still subs remember you're still the harem remember you're still
You're still little little little boy bitches
Got the mole prostate what the fuck huh? Congrats a 4k. Did we hit 4k?
Let's fucking go. I'm gonna strangle you. Oh, yeah celebratory strangle. Uh
Get choked get choked get choked get choked bitch get choked get on your knees get on your knees
Ready ready say ah say ah
Good job
Hey
But thank you for 4k
Waiting for youtube to catch up. Um with the monetization stuff
Because we all hit our like the watch hours on debut
But we have to wait like a week to set up the monetization almost like how twitch does um with um
What you ever called all my stuff's gonna get demonetized anyways, but you know, it's whatever
Maybe I just want to hug too bad cry harder
You smell like tea. It's good tea. It's lemon ginger tea with a little bit of like a rich root throat coat
Please don't zoom like that. I'm watching my phone at work. What do you mean like what?
What are you talking about like what wait, do you have your volume turned on?
Oh, oh, oh my god
I'm sorry. I might have been mildly inspired by a certain someone who's like
Who is reacting to someone saying? Oh, I have my um volume up and I'm on a bus because I can't hear that well
And so she started just screaming the most terrible things
Oh streams not gonna survive. Uh, no the stream is gonna survive. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it
I know who you're talking about. Okay. Yeah
I think you're cool or something
Uh, let's you we're doing a new game because we never played before
No mistake
I'm a sociopath
God that sounded evil. Let's rewind a little I grew up all over coastal america
House after house after restraining order
Everything just kind of blends in if the divorce rate is 50 50 my mom landed on tails like eight times
So by the time I was 14, you've never seen this before so we have to watch it
You know and attended six different school districts after a while
You don't see a point in making friends the vitamin c graduation song. Yeah, I can't relate
But then one year all of that almost changed. I'm gonna eat a lozen
I found myself in a school for two consecutive years going on three and then I like started turning three into high school
so the guys hitting on you social leverage was
I've never played ace attorney
I've only ever watched game grumps play it
Like they had always been pretty
never left out
This feels like a viewer debut and when I think about it
All the thinking I never done was when I was alone
I was nice about it and thought I'd always be nice about it
Finally in one place to build a steady reputation
And then life said fuck that my piece of shit gamer brother got us evicted for pirating break beat
Again, I love the piano. I mean not again. This is the first time. Um, the moving boxes and how she reads
We're moving out of state and I just got settled. They said, fuck you. I'm living with
Oh, yeah, game grumps is my and markiplier my my comfort
YouTubers
My second christmas killed himself. I walked in. I usually
look like a whole ass video game just blood everywhere and get this
His suicide note. I usually have them in the background when I'm doing stuff because I can't focus unless I hear noise
I'm Nicole by the way. Hi. What the fuck did I do to him? Maybe I missed the office softball game
Men are so into this revenge suicide house party playthrough. Oh my god. I would love to play house party
I'm moving
again
city county state
all the same fate
Watch gerba. I need to watch gerba because I feel like he's right up my alley
And then I like I just watched Jenna marbles. She's also my comfort youtuber even though she's not a pro anymore
I think I'm trying to remember I think for my senior prank. Oh my god, I can't fucking pause
Yeah, like fuck mr. Brubin a dude
Please
I don't know why they don't let you pause this part
German marbles. Oh my god a collab between them
Wow, yeah, that was funny. Yeah, I'm getting into like humor and stuff. Anyway
Okay, now I can pause uh
so
my school
um
was really weird
and
not
like
creative
like the the apparently the seniors before us like let a pig into the
uh school
The game is full auto. Yeah. I I there's nothing I can do about it
I can
Fuck um
But then what we did for our senior prank was just
Take every chair in the building
And put it in the gymnasium
So like I don't even know how they did that
I think the janitor like let them into the school and like unlock shit for them
and they just
but
And then
Yeah
And then there's a senior skip day where everybody skipped school
um
And I went to school
On senior skip day
Listen, I wasn't cool enough
Well, I was I like like I was growing up
I was the girl so like I've said before like I was a really religious christian girl
So I was uh a target for like um
Upper classmen and stuff
Uh
So I remember like other like the popular senior boys would try to corrupt me
And so they're like, oh you want to come to the beach with us and I was like, uh, no
Because I won I was oblivious
to
I just wanted I had stuff to do that day, you know, I had to hop on wolf quest
How to read my warrior cats
How are you feeling about the lord these days? I'm a pagan bro
Me and emmy we on that witch shit me emmy and mercy we on that witch shit
Why do you think you're in love with us? We hex you
Don't wear your cat's face
What's wolf quest?
Actually, I was thinking more games to play next week. Maybe I might change it to wolf quest
Actually, no, I have to do that the week after because they already made our thumbnails and I feel bad
I'm catholic. I'm so sorry
um
Honestly, uh
Like oh make a verse
um
If you have any sort of religious affiliation you do you
I don't care either way as long as you don't care what I do either way because I definitely want to do tarot streams with emmy and stuff
It's fun
It's fine. Thank you rpg. Enjoyer for your permission. I think I can figure it out. The hex girls exactly. Oh
Like those sorry those girls were hot as fuck like a school tour. You want to do that? You after that flavor pagan my own flavor
I uh I danced to the beat of my own drum baby girl to the school tour
So then my friend got the dlc. There's downloadable content. Is he mansplaining downloadable content for the gun?
Why are you talking to me about video games?
Just something you know, uh
What you don't like play video games. I hate video games. I'm a thin girl. Do I fucking look like I play video games?
You have a kamioshi. You'll never know
Oh
Well
I don't like convention
We have those
I'm not gonna lie for like a week straight
Um when I was in school people were like freaking out about this
And like that's literally everybody you could talk about and I
I didn't even know what it meant
How my name is chrispen. Well, you never read the book chrispen great book
As chrispen glover
mount and
dude
Pump up the sound got you baby girl
Hey, stop kicking it. This backpack holds priceless reading materials. Oh, yeah, like what the burn scene bears make eye contact
See they smoke burn see in the right the normal way. It is home to some of my favorite manga books
Mandela effect. What is it like Asian or something? Oh, he said manga correctly. Thank you
Some of which go on to be very popular television shows. Wait, can't you watch half those on cartoon channels?
Why the hell would you read it?
That's it. Dude, how do you care about anything this much? What happened to the school tour?
Okay, he thinks your chinese cartoon your chinese cartoon books stay out of this you you girl
You girl uh, I'm gonna watch him get beat up just because of that
I'll just let this play out. I should beat your ass for like an anime. What what are you talking about? Yeah, do it. I'm bored
Yeah, do it. Yeah. Yeah, don't pull my hair
Don't pull my hair glasses. I got a split. Oh, yeah, me too. You wouldn't hit a guy with glasses with you
Around
Well, aren't you running off with that? Okay. Are you guys fighting below me right now?
What are you guys doing? Reina is growling
What is happening boomie stop pestering her
They're pussies. I'm not afraid to watch someone grovel in pain
Well, they're all just assholes that guy's been making fun of me for like an anime since the sixth grade
Then just stop liking anime
But I can't do that anime is my favorite thing ever my life
The voice acting is so good
In consumption. Are you trying to make anime? I don't get it
Kind of can't interrupt it fan art based on the works of sento takahashi
You know that anime will exist with or without you, right? No
Wait, what do you mean like senti takamoki would have the fucking mean is he wouldn't care. He wouldn't even know
What's your point? How do you give a fuck about anything that doesn't give a fuck about you?
Hey in a translated newsletter
He said thank you to each and every one of his fans. That includes me. Oh, he writes in english
No, his fan club translated into japanese. That's my point. He can't even talk to you. You think he cares about you
Well for the longest time
I wasn't allowed to watch anime because again growing up religious my parents saw like a little majority of anime
has like demonic undertones in terms of like, oh, she's a demon or oh
Magic like I wasn't allowed to read harry potter for the longest time
Then I grew up my dad's like, I don't really give a fuck and I'm like, thank you and I read the first book and I'm like
This is mid as fuck. Are you kidding me?
So I yeah, like I remember I had I said this before in my thank my two point
No, I had to like sneak and watch adult swim and like full metal alchemist on mute and Naruto
You know the first Naruto episode I watched neji neji dying
I was crying at this random anime character. I never formed an attachment to
spoiler neji dies, um
Going super sane to my well, it's funny because my dad watched dragon ball z
so that was fine
so like
Part one or part two, what do you mean?
movies are better
like of of what
Dory mom
No, like
Like I was the type of kid that liked the fantasy and like magic stuff. I wasn't like the slice of life kind
Like so I wasn't like if I was watching like slice of life anime. I think my parents wouldn't have cared
I didn't watch any of that. I didn't want to didn't interest me
I'm like, I want to see people fight each other
What the heck is going on
Chat broke. Oh god
Guys, are you with me?
You still there breathe breathe deeply. Okay. You're still there
I don't watch anime is
You should get on that
the dark raised me um
I always say like I remember my mom was like, oh I hate anime
But I think she only said that because like, you know, it was like the thing to hate anime
But my dad liked it. So I don't fucking get it. Um
It's funny, right?
Like I'm like realizing how much like my parents are like, you can't do this thing
Then they would just go and do that thing
And this is so funny
Um, but then my mom saw kiki's delivery service and she fell in love and I'm like what?
I'm like, like this is about like a witch who does bake like it's a witch mom
Woo, which is the devil and she's just like, but it's cute and then she just ended up not caring
My mom. Yeah, my mom's favorite, um studio ghibli film is
uh
Is a kiki's delivery service and I think my dad's is uh
What is it?
Uh porco rosco, I can't
I
Yeah, porco rosso. I'm like, it's not rosco rosso
Uh, I love toro. I have a lot of toro stuff. Um, I remember I've had like the same toro hoodie for like
I'll like 10 years
How was moving castle is my personal favorite?
I'd rather be a pig than a fascist. Um
Be it was the
So I said my first studio ghibli movie I ever watched was the cat returns and I fell in love with the cat
in the the fun hat
And then I watched how was moving castle and I fell in love with howl really hard
I like especially like christian like christian bail. I don't
Only up until recently like a couple years ago. I didn't know that christian bail voice howl
Oh
And I yeah, how was moving castle is one of my all-time faves tales of mercy is very good. Yes
My first anime's pokemon. I wasn't allowed to play or watch pokemon because um, I remember being at church and they had this like
thing
Where they said like oh
um
Do not be swayed by
The kids these days playing their pokemon because it is pocket monsters aka the devil
They're demons you based off of demons in japanese culture. They're being glorified and kids
Kids media and so I wasn't allowed to
play or watch pokemon
That I stole a pokemon game from gamestop and I never looked back
Uh
Pokemon fire red
My game boy
And then I had um, actually no, I didn't steal from gamestop. I stole it from a kid who brought it to our
my after-school program
So true sister of the claw and um, yeah, they're like, oh, I'll let you borrow this game. I just never gave it back
Yeah
And I yeah, I played the I played a lot of pokemon games since and then I also convinced like my
Relatives to get me like pokemon games. I'm not like the hugest pokemon fan, but I definitely love it like like it a lot
Uh, it was I was definitely it was that and in ton dogs. I played this shit out of
Truly the christian way to play pokemon
Oh
Like so I went to like after school program
After school
And then like we'd all we'd have like a attack day where we could bring in our like ds's and our game boys and all that shit
and um
I would just
So I like and then like I didn't I didn't have a lot of games because I was broke as fuck
I had like my like a wealthier grandparent got me my game boy and my ds
And so I would just steal
But it was yeah after school program after school. Yeah, exactly
That was that that place that place if I didn't go to that place I would be
a social outcast because thankfully that place because my parents worked late
um
Allowed me to
Have some social skills. I'm just happy my mom didn't pull me out of high school
My freshman year because I almost got pulled because she wanted to homeschool me
Because a lot of uh people at my church were doing that
And then I end up with fucking
A girl like emily magie or whatever the fuck in my church who has doesn't know how to talk to people
So I'm happy I didn't turn out like that
I'm only supposed to be caught in me
Ex-homeschooling. Yeah, definitely dodge the bullet especially because I'm an only child
What a fucking sucks man
Early stream it's an early stream baby girl
Okay, you want to stick to getting beat up over children's media? I'll leave you to it. Wait
Oh, yeah, I had the rebellious teen phase my mom fucking hated me
Not many people when you're when you're growing up you always knock heads with your parent of the same gender
And me my mom definitely knocked heads, but
um
I love her to death. She's like
One of the people I look up to the most in my life aside from my dad
My mom's a fucking badass and I thank her every day for putting up the shit. I put her through
Or as nice to me as you are that was nice to you god damn it. Yeah, I'm jeffrey by the way. What's your name?
Uh, nicole
Wow
Okay, bye nicole. Yeah. Yeah, okay
Oh, you look new the lunch line's on the other end there. Huh?
You're trying to find where the lunch line starts, right? You got here a little late. So it's pretty long now
Oh, will she appear on stream? Um, my parents said they do want to come on stream at some point
Where'd you come in from? Probably just like recorded stuff though because they would probably
Docs my whole name address social security number mother's made a name, etc, etc
Or like how can he afford someone to add her all with a jab at the shop?
Yeah, everybody's everybody's stuff is different. I think like girls usually knock heads with their mothers bull cut
That's jeffrey. I don't think he's all there like he's too socially awkward for the normal people
But too smart for the special eddies
Can I sit here? Yeah, sure. All my friends got put in a different lunch period. One day you'll blow up
I'm nicole. I'm gonna be fair. You also had to put up with some shit. That's like all your births
Yeah, you know for jessica avi
That's pretty cool. I'm unpacked that shit in my therapy sessions. So my parents
Even my parents have gotten a lot more lax with that. Like they don't give a shit what I do now
I remember they found my tarot cards. They're just like just don't do it in the house. Like it was fucking drugs
You ready for day two
Is someone gonna kill me day two? If so, absolutely. Why what happened?
Just like waking up in general hurts and I got a deal with my brother who's still up from the night
Oh, yeah, my parents are pretty cool. They're definitely they were surprisingly. They're way
Less strict like 26 other people's parents that I grew up with
I mean, we way less strict like if you thought like, oh your parents have been really strict
Compared to other people's parents. No, I have to tell them that when I'm woken up by loud chewing noises
Is he fat?
Do you know what x bodybuilder is your dad's single my parents are happily married
Well, he's an obese monster. I was just curious if anyone else
Says me. Oh no, I'm hiding all that shit. Let's gossip more at lunch. I gotta get to class
Dude, fuck class. Just skip with me. I told you yesterday if I skip anymore
My mom's gonna start giving me disciplinary tattoos. Oh god
I was largely raised by my grandparents for interactions with my mom and brother's not pleasant
Yeah, truly and it's like they also have their own shit. They have to work through
Huh do they have an upside down pineapple? Oh my god
I only discovered like a couple months ago what that meant. They do not
Okay, we're gonna go we're not going to photography
Look, it's the first day. No funny guys. No comedians. No bring us to the ha ha, okay
This year's gym class isn't last year's gym class. We're gonna really buckle down on physical fitness
I ain't buckling shit
Young lady. What's your name? Nicole. You want my phone number two?
This is only the first class that can bring us up the ha ha ha
No, sorry. Good. Now everybody better dress out every class if you don't it's a zero hit the locker rooms
I'll see you back. I got negative marks so often because I would constantly
forget to
Bring clothes to change into
Showing our education system is pure evil. He's even Mario on a shirt. Talk like a cartoon
What do you mean if I talk like a cartoon I'd go. What's up doc? No, it's just general ha ha
I'm random cartoon channel talk. Have you ever watched television for adults?
What do you mean like porn?
I see that there's only two forms of media to watch porn and cartoons
Uh
Wait, I totally missed what
I like some wild porn here and there probably wouldn't handle it
Actually, I want to see I want to see if he'll tell me what he watches
Most girls just scream and run when I say that
I bet he's gonna talk to me about hentai or something
Well, are you gonna tell me or not? Why do you want to know?
Uh, everybody knows the coolest guys have depraved fetishes. I mean, yeah guys, the coolest guys have depraved fetishes
Uh, uh, all right
See me on lunch today. Maybe we could talk about it then lunch date with jeffree
Finally someone to share my escape is if you talk about vtubers, that would be peak
Yeah, I get lost in all these weird websites to get away from my gun nut stepdad
I think he was in iraq or something doesn't matter anyway. Wait. It was stepdad and you don't
know if he actually served in iraq
That's so that you think like possibly go wrong. What was that? Oh, just I've wanted a chat like this for so long
I wanted a chat like this stares at you for so long
Oh, he would like a zura
Is jeffree base guys jeffree base
Really, uh, is this a is this the average, uh, a zura fan right here?
Huh, you know most people hate when they're taken advantage of no, I mean
Literally walk all over me
Love to be stepped on by a cute tariff feet. Well, hey beat stepping on a scale. Okay, so he's one of my fans too
Unfortunately, most of my fetishes can only be realized through my anime
The realm of the living isn't quite ready for 50 foot tall vixens
Yeah, the real world sucks. We're walking into the jeffree route. Did I mention how I liked girls with cat ears and tails?
What about bunny ears and tails?
Oh my god, are we gonna take jeffree's virginity?
I'm yawing in his virginity if that's if that's a thing. I'm yawing in it. It's mine
I wonder if the library has volume 31 yet. Hey there jeffree. I'm corrupting this anime loser
Oh, hello, jacka. Unfortunately jacka. He used my toothbrush to clean out his new assault rifle
He bought from china. How much up much?
Anyway, could you find another card? He's been revoked. Sorry, but I can't anymore
My mom's been wondering where all my lunch money's been going. Oh, you mean you don't like me anymore
Again, I'm sorry. I just don't know. Maybe I should grow 40 feet. Then you don't really like me
She told other people
Maybe if you took your shoes off and stepped on his face. Oh, no. Oh, no
Oh, he's going to do something to the school
Oh, yeah, they're kids with the popped up kids
Yes, come on. We'll make us purrs. I can't believe this
Uh, I was actually very nice to the jeffree in my school because
Well, all along the notes flattering
Literally batch it crazy. Like he wasn't like he was nerdy, but he was also like
Like I'm not even joking. He was crazy
Uh, like he would have definitely
Done bad things
And I remember even it was like that
thing
He even told me one time
Like thank you. Like you've like a really good friend of mine and that again
I was just doing the bare minimum of kindness because I'm I'm gonna be kind to anyone
I'm not it's really hard for me to dislike someone and as someone who was bullied
I just did not bully other people
And he was like, you know, you're one of the good ones and I'm like, oh, thanks redacted and he's like, yeah
If I did that, you know that joke of like coming to school with stuff like I definitely like warned you first and I was like
What
What do you mean
And he's like, haha, don't worry about it. And then he just like walked away
And then so I used to work at um
I used to work at game stop for for a bit
Sadly I didn't have any stock in their company
But and then he like came in looking for oh, but I will give you stories about when I worked at game stop
Don't you worry about that?
um, and he came in and
It was like really late like we were about to close and he was like, oh my god redacted
Chibi, it's so good to see you and I'm like, oh, hey redacted
And then he's like, oh like it's like that's in a caught up with him or whatever
and then um
He was like, oh, I want to show you something and then he just
Started showing me hentai on his phone
And I look at my manager who he also happened to be friends with and no and mind you my manager was a jeffrey
down to the core
And he's like as long as you can't see it in the cameras and I'm like
I can go home like it's time for me to punch punch out right like
Can I leave
And then you know, I don't know what they did after that because I left. Yeah
Yep
Yeah, it's it's it's it's I don't even remember what it was because I glanced at it
I generally I can't recall what it was
Uh
Yeah, you're working at game stop
What was the trip? You know those things of like the moms coming in and being like hi
I'd like to buy my son the fishing game
and I'm like, oh like what like, um
What the fuck is that fishing game called? That's super popular
Not compelling. That's the hunting game. But um
And I'm like what she's like cod
I'm like call of duty
She's like, yeah past 400
um
I'm like ma'am
That's not a fishing game
And she's like it's not but it's called my son. He's like 11. It's called cod. He's like he said he wanted to fish with his friends
I'm like and I pull up the game
And like mind you again, I get I would get fired if I like sold somebody underage a game
And um, I also had like a holier than thou save your complex at the time
So I held up the game cover to her
And I'm like ma'am does this look like a fishing game to you?
And it was I think it was like black ops three where the guy's like kneeling with like the two guns
she's just like
Oh, no, it doesn't
like
I think she would have caught on when she saw the game cover but
I
The parents I know like I bet I bet he ended up getting it another way
I remember like some kid brought his psp to the my after school program
And we all gathered around watching him play gta on the psp and like with the strippers
And we're all like
Cod like strong strong is a call fish get it get it right
You start a game stop from these stories. You were oh, yeah, and being a girl it was just
It was just funny like I would just have like
The weirdest dudes hit on me and I'd be like
Would you like to sign up for our game stops rewards? Oh if I can get your number
Okay, so it looks like you're not signing up for game stop rewards. Let me just check you out
Oh, I'm buying BMX access for eight year old son. What? Oh my god
Oh my god
and like
And I was like I was very alternative and like scenish the way I dress so I was just like
Just like a seed and goth looking chick just that cave stop
Like
Uh really super depressed all the time only got a job because I needed money
And my parents made me get a job because I was in need
Oh my god, anyways game
Bad bitch on my office door. I'll start tracking who left them if it continues
Well, it definitely wasn't jeffrey. Oh
Fuck you are done. Why is it definitely not jeffrey? Because you're not a cat
Oh my god, I just noticed the outfit he was wearing Jesus fuck and you should all be ashamed of yourselves
Oh, thank you. I was really just because he prefers alternative forms of sexual intercourse does not mean he should be ridiculed
Sorry
What do you mean by
alternative
Oh god jeffrey here prefers to be stepped on by women who look like cats as opposed to standard intercourse with a human woman
Oh my god, this stop. I feel so bad
You did this
Did what?
Told everyone my darkest secret. Oh, he's killing me first. That was in confidence
I was hoping we would just like sorry give him a nice lay. I feel bad
I haven't touched my manga in forever
Not even cartoons entertain me anymore. Oh, he's like talking normal
Do you even care?
Do the results of your actions mean anything to you? I'm very scared when they affect me. Sure
No one in the realm of the living ever liked me anyway. Oh, no, I feel really bad
Damn it, Nicole
Because you're gonna fucking shake me
No, jeffrey don't do it jeffrey you're based your tastes. You're so based bro
Don't do it home slice
Don't kill yourself. You're so sexy
Girl hormones make me feel guilty
call his bluff
Well, I'm I'm getting guilty because I feel like he would actually do it
I mean, you don't have to kill yourself over this. Do you?
In the realm of the living I am nothing more than a punchline for others amusement
This is not the purpose I desired
Well, what is
I don't know
So if you die now, you'll never know
Don't try to talk me out of yeah, if I call this bluff. He probably would have shot up the school
What are you fool? He thought of the oldest cause never get in the land war between
Eight that's the end of the world. What's the line ever get? I literally love the princess bride so much
So you want more than missionary big deal? Okay, so it's not the end of the world. It's still the end of my social life
Jeffrey what social life all you did was repeating the sweetheart location stop it
Stop it
So what's the problem seems like everything's going according to plan
You know
You're right
The only thing that's different is everyone knows when you learn like not to care what other people think it's literally life changing
They just assumed it
Gosh, thanks, Nicole
I'm a woman. So I still care about what people think but you know
When you mostly stop caring about people
Company this is what empathy gets you
Come on, I just wanted to sleep with Jeffrey
I
Nicole I'm trying to make a depression playlist on itunes. What is it? Well nothing really?
I'm just wondering why you've been so exhausted lately. I'm depressed mom mom. You're being nice, right?
Trying to get along. Yeah, and I'm pretty sure that's my problem never putting up a fight never telling men
I'm not their emotional wheelchair
Well, sweetie, I'm not sure if being confrontational is the key to happiness
Your beautiful girl don't have an ugly personality personality towards anyone
So I should like spread myself thin. I don't care what others think or say part of the perk of being a nerd
Being a virgin all I'm saying is and having hot girls try to steal your chance
What if they're bad people? I don't believe anyone being inherently bad
Yeah, I guess the pedophiles trying to abduct me on my space or just misunderstood
I remember I tried making a mind space when I was like 10
My dad was like no the connections you start early come in handy later
Although I was on guy online when I was 10. That was a bad idea
Fine
Thank you. I promise it'll pay off
He just becomes Jeff the killer
Okay, whatever now my mom's addicted to heroin again
Oh, shit. Well, that sucks. I thought everyone would just forget about the hangout promises
I made over the winter the thing where you tell them you're really busy for midterms
But should have time in the spring. Yeah, I thought most of them would just forget not when you're hot
They never forget when you're hot. I'm hot. You fish by the classic
I mean when I was 30 making a mind space my dad said no because I'm 56
Park or the diner. What kind of Mormon ass bitch meets at a diner
They all play together couldn't tell you
Worst part is I'm at this point where I'm too nice to even decline the follow-up hangers. Hey, let's do this again
Maybe next week same time. Yeah, so now it's the bullshit
I put up with on break combined with the bullshit I put up with at school
Really makes you question the whole point of nice. I love guy. I asked you about their economy
When shit socializing honestly kind of sucks now
And nobody plays the game anymore. Yeah, I like logs into my old account
Oh my god, you're bad and um, that's like church girl. Nice. I went to like the racing place and like other places
Like like nobody's there. He'll just stalk me. I'll be so cynical. I'll probably just murder you
Dying would be awesome right now, but I feel like there'd be strings attached with him
You're dead. What could he possibly do your body is disappear when you die
So whatever his twisted little anime brain wants. Oh, okay
But if he actually killed you could I take your body to attack the dermis be pretty sick
Good to know. Hell yeah, we're all on the same page. Did you end up on habo? I like I think when I played habo hotel like once
I mostly stuck to gaya and neopets
And wet paint and real players guilt. It's just been wild crazy. That's the fourth time you said that
Oh, uh
Pretty sweet. Your mom's out of town. You could throw a whole party, right?
Are you gonna throw a party people enough to let them destroy my house? Then yeah, absolutely
Oh, man, don't be a downer. Do you kind of remind me of this one girl from a local punk band around here?
She kind of gets a penguin. Hell yeah, I was
You want to this fucked up shit I used to do so
I usually like
Uh, I growing up. I don't know why I did this, but I posed as a boy
on
a club penguin
I remember I
posed as a as a boy and I was like my name's kyle
and then
I made another account
Called sky and she was my sister
So I
kyler
so I would
Switch between the accounts
And I would pretend to be a bro to the people I played with and then I would switch to be a girl
And they would tell me they have a crush on my sister aka me
and then
I was so but like I was like, I don't even know how old it was doing that. I would I lark to siblings often
I guess I was just so manhara as a child and I really wish I had a sibling that I could
fuck people over with because even you know when I played counter strike
I I put like because I could do my guy voice
And then I would say oh you want to hear my like my sister wants to play and then I'd switch to my normal voice and then people
People would believe it because you know mics back then were terrible. There's two wolves inside me my two fake siblings
A
Two fake the girl and boy siblings the the and the andy and the
Andy and ashley. Oh my fucking god. They were literally andy and ashley
Not the realization is bro still single. I don't know
Bro, I was crazy as fuck like
like
When I was a kid, no, I'm not gonna get it. I'll have to get into that and like a zassi stream just like
my tulpas
We should play that. Oh, I've already I've actually already played through confident mandy and lele
But I'm totally be down to play it again. And then the next episode come comes out
Back when I was a priestess
She does something soon of her did uh, she does something soon of her. She's something similar. I'm not surprised
She'd be your ways to indulge your sister for a corner
Leave me alone
People were people were like I thought she was based because of how I responded to a marrow when it's real life
I just don't like it. I'm sorry
Previews for episode three. Oh, I haven't even seen the previews
Uh, emmy's playing coffin of andy and lele today, isn't she?
So you guys will have a little treat you guys will get a little treat you want to treat you want to treat
You know a little treat then
I also really like to take her in kairu
for more in high school
Uh
So the fanfic turn out. Why did you retract that?
I'm reading
What did you say?
I was reading that um, I actually next week. I'm doing a fanfic fan fix reading. So if
I I've read my immortal
Before so if you have anything in the vein of my immortal
Send it my way. I'll probably make like some sort of google google form or you just like I'll make a tweet
You guys can like tag me what you want me to read. Um
Uh, I'm not gonna ever respond to the guy's marrow, but this is yeah, I'm like, it's fucking funny because I'm like, what are you?
Um, my immortal was good. I maybe I'll read that again because my immortal you can't
Uh, I've read my immortal multiple times. That's peak peak cinema
Peak uh stuff or read some creepypossesses. Ooh, or if you have some safe for work fanfics
to write about me
meme or the girls
and me
Please I will put out a tweet and you can submit them. In fact, I should probably do that
What's today thursday?
What day is it?
It's fra- holy shit. It's friday. I thought it was like wednesday
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Oh my god
Uh, time flies when you're a big titty dandy McGraw on the internet. Um, but yeah
So I guess I'll maybe I'll put that tweet up today because I what day am I gonna do that?
Oh
I have to keep logging in to my schedule
Fanfiction oh fuck what is that?
Can't read
Three days. Okay. Well, yeah, I'm putting up that tweet today because it's on the 10th
that I'm reading fanfictions
Goku and Anne like Anne Frank
You're fucking with me. Are you serious?
SCPs. Oh, yeah, that'd be cool
Thing just more like the band makes her image that
I like how I'm gonna like not stream for like a couple hours and come back
Has it really only been 20 minutes? Hey, I just want to let you know
You're actually really pretty
I know pretty and like pretty cool, too
You taste music. It's like it's like nothing I've ever heard before you really know your stuff
No, I don't I had Sean Kingston
Oh
You're different
I'm not having sex with you an actual name. Yes talking about fucking you was like the last thing very correct
You've worn the same volcom socks for like two weeks. I'm looking to fight strong guys. I heard imperial germany is pretty
It's cool if it is
Why are we at davin busters? Yeah, it might seem crowded now, but you should see this place
Am I just like speed dating everybody? I said you should see this place on friday. It's friday. Okay
You see me at the hoops machine. I'm sick. You couldn't keep up. I like she's like actually
Hanging out with everybody 17 after all and the ski ball suicidal pregnancy. Don't take it too hard
I make everyone look trash at it. All of this. I don't mind davin busters. All right. Yeah, tell the pussy ass bitches to suck my dick
I think I should start making rap songs. My dad is a mac book
I love it
Poor speedrun, but yeah season four not really for me personally. How about you? Sorry season four of what now the doki-dice-ki anime
You've been paying attention right to the first three seasons or are you talking for the last 20 minutes?
Actually, it's the same answer for both. Yeah, I know
What were the writers thinking?
I'm actually involved with an online group and we're gonna reanimate
Come on, you won't let me take this boy's virginity like a whole hand it over
Yeah, let me corrupt this little nerd use all the help we could get
I guess animation takes a lot of time, right?
At least we don't have time to stream with audio. That's actually audible. Actually, we haven't found an
Is that supposed to mean yeah, but one of our friend's cousins might do it after he graduates from media school
You turn Nicole into a pushover. I really fucking did. Yeah, just for the love of the show
Well, honestly, it's good for her because she needs more friends and they're open. Why not her?
There's no difference whether I join or not join because this will never be made
Well, if you feel that way
Do you know why it's so hard to find animators? I don't know why the fuck I'm here
I even had to pay for my own shitty cheeseburger. I'm gonna start telling men. I'm vegan so they stop trying to take me places
That's pretty pretty good strat
But yeah, Kelly's a fucking whore and I hope she dies end of discussion. Goddamn. I'm not opposed to that stance. How about you, Nicole?
Nicole, huh? Oh, sorry. I'm the exhausted somehow socially burnt out like her
Poor new kid. It's like, you know, they want to fuck but they won't just ask so you can reject them
I know right like you guys
Are made to serve me and you know, make me my food and buy me my food. Thank you for reminding me
About it. Let's just enjoy your cancerous meatloaf in peace. I'm sorry
Oh, Nicole. What's up? Who's still on for tonight? Fucking chrisbin
Why is it all guys? Why am I not hanging out with girls?
Cole concert's gonna be sick with you there. The government is bad that concert was tonight
You are exhausted. I was playing literal. No bodies. Just cover bands. You can say no. Oh my god
To say no
Yeah, someone told me they saw you at a place with that weird japan kid. Japan kid
Well, you actually went through with that. You need to have some kind of limit
How can I rank who and who not to hang out with when they're all equally shitty to me?
Just are you suicidal? Don't hang out with anyone. Just hang out with the girls
Seriously though. Yes. Why would that cell be rubby?
Same. Open your mouth. Don't let them stick your feet in there.
Maybe you should just blow off that concert. I won't hear the end of it
It's facts. Can't please everyone.
Also facts. Good strat. Uh, I'm gonna stay home and kill myself
I think that's a pretty good idea
I like she's like I'm going zero to a hundred. I don't want to go to a concert. I'm gonna kill myself
Say no, whatever. I want to die. It doesn't matter how
I don't understand
Oh my god, she went through it with that
What did I even do what did she do?
My daughter attempted suicide. There's blood everywhere, police said
Did the old slice and dice?
My 13th reason oh my god, like happy happy
13 reasons why I was so fucked up. I actually I like the book was good. I didn't like seeing it in person
Mom had me locked up in a mental ward until my 18th birthday. So I learned what crazy pills actually do to you
They don't make anyone happier
Just more content with limbo
What sucks worse than killing yourself is fucking up. Can't wait to get fainzily because I just want to bang people and I can't
Bang anybody in this game shot for eternity
You're just really awkward to hang out with
Can't wait to play hoonipop. Oh
We were playing hoonipop so fast those games. I've been sitting
Covered in dust in my steam library for years. I have never I've seen gameplay. I know the premise
I have never played the game myself though. I bought them. I bought
I literally I think I bought every hoonipop game because they're on sale
All right
Make
Yeah, I'm I'm speedrunning everything
We're gonna cut close this time
Well, wait most I've ever met would mean you stand out in some way. You're a very run-of-the-mill waste of time
I was at the first ending. I went to some street. It's the first time we played it
I don't want you to talk about us first you wear classic rock t-shirts from walmart
Remember to play it uncensored and cover it with stream overlay and then fail a few times
Well, if it's on fans, it's gonna be uncensored. Cool rapid fire of assumptions. Tell me if I get any wrong
I'm not gonna like
Fuck around that. Take pictures of your skin. I know like mostly. I know the girls just want to get our fans
These so that we can play
naughty games
Well
All right, I'll see you later then. I also call it honey pop
Hey, I've seen your ass around here before honey pop. It's my first day. Are you sure about that?
Whatever all you hot girls look to say. Yeah, I think maybe that's what I got it
What it was like gotta be really really cutting under this school security
It's a lot of air. I've actually never played energy games to be honest. Are you bad bitch or what?
I'm an abysmal bitch like the closest thing I got to playing energy games was like really bad cheerleading
Doesn't visual novels without tommy games
Last season we went seven and five like above 500 not bad. It's my life pretty much
How can you make lacrosse your life? There's no pro league for it. Is there is there? Well, I'm sure they're out there
Besides we only lost like five games because I fucked my knee up and couldn't play the rest of the season
It's pretty bad ass because they keep giving me percussa. Cool. Seriously. How much my younger self would be horrified
Elephant I got them right here. You want to do it with me? They only know I think my younger self would be like damn
You are cool as fuck
um
Should we pop some percussets percusset molly percusset
Did I didn't know that song did it in the net should we decline the free drugs? So we say no to drugs kids
Are we popping them perks?
Flute
Pop them pop. All right, we pop perks free percusset. Hell. Yeah, hand it over
This is actually my mexican cartel supply, but it probably won't kill you
My feet feel great. I could fall asleep standing right now. Yeah, I told you it was good shit
I'm sorry. Are we lost? Both of you should be in class. This isn't a skip. Why do we just like have it sell out?
In his pocket in his pants hiding there my dick. Oh shit prescription pills. Who's are these?
Actually, it doesn't matter. You're my wife is dead
Um avoid getting murdered for snitching
Huh pin it on the other guy. I don't really get these
Am I gonna pin it on kyler?
Or i'm just not gonna say anything at all
No, i'm not gonna go down. I'll go down with him. I'm gonna snitch. I ain't no fucking snitch, bro
In trouble. Fuck you. I'm not in anything. Uh, yeah, you definitely are in trouble
Well, you're in the model train fan club. You freak. I'm not in the model train fan club
I just sponsored the model train fan club. That's even worse. No snitching. You look new here. I'm not sure what you think you're doing
If I can assure you it won't last long. A bitch can't pop perks here. What the fuck? What if I have glaucoma?
But you don't have glaucoma and you just confessed to drug use on school grounds. Come with me both of you
glaucoma?
Honey their background sound. Yeah, it's fucking AC. A two-day suspension on the first day of school
It was like one pill. He's just mad. I made him feel insecure. So he threw the book at me
Look, I know you're acting out because of your father mom. Literally. No one ever has actively thought I'm gonna act out today
What does that even mean? I'm gonna look like disrespecting my parents
This is a world you and everyone who crochet is created. She kind of has a point with that, bob
You kind of need to get a fucking job. You're 26
I told you the economy's bad blame bush and these girls I chat with online fully agree
Mom still I can't believe you're taking the school side with this. It's totally against all my citizen rights
They had you sign something that waves those rights. You're 16. You don't even have rights
Well, you do right through the school or something. You're at the only public school for miles and miles
What happens if you're gone for good, huh? I'm not moving again. I'm not paying for private school
And I'm definitely not home
Fine, I won't blow it then. I won't squeal a bit
I was your dream. I saw your friends in Dallas, but I won't say a word because we got to stay in this shithole
Good. I'm glad we understand each other mom. I could just get assaulted. You wouldn't care
You've been pulling the sexual assault card since you were 12 hasn't happened yet. Has it Jesus Christ
Point well, you can figure out a new excuse locked in your bedroom for the next two days
Fine. I have my own computer grounding doesn't do shit anymore
Yeah, baby, you hear this? It's kind of true though. Like now join my party chat. We can game
What the fuck are you doing? It's 1 a.m. We're going back to school tomorrow
You're gonna be seriously failing now
Seriously, you may fail. Those boys don't even go together. You sound like an idiot
Look, I'm just recording a little voice message for this hottie I met online that I'm done, okay?
This is like the fifth hottie in two days. Do you know how old any of these girls are? Yikes
Like legal in her country. Don't worry about it. Oh my god. This is bad
I'm just trying to score some 15 year old canadian ass hop off it
Brother is calling her Canadian ass doesn't make that better
Well, no, you know how like canadian bacon is just hand
Canadian ass is just a mature 15 year old. See same thing
Oh my god, could you just help me record this message so we could both go to bed quicker?
Okay
AKA do I
Do I help my brother groom a girl or do
Or do I allow him and get him to jail or do I just distract him?
Why do you want me to help him?
Don't joke about it if you have to delete this one too. I don't know what you're talking about
Definitely a certified lover boy. Yeah, we're gonna distract him. Hey, why don't you go have some cheetos and play xbox big bro?
Hey, um, did you get that new shooter game the one where you're a white guy shooting brown people in a non-racist
Oh, I was in evil four
I had to steal out of mom's purse, but it's get paid or get played. You know what I mean
Uh
Yeah, I guess
Can I play with you? I thought you didn't like video games anymore
I started using an anti aging cream wasn't very evil five. Oh fuck. Sorry resident evil five my joke
My joke would have been so fun here. Don't woman not like video games
Oh god damn it wasn't getting suspended but getting suspended on the first day before meeting anyone
Because I I think I was like was I playing? I think I
Hey, what's up? Are you playing or watching someone for a couple days? I can't fucking remember
Jesus christ
They don't even give them like the are you new here like uh, I'm back from a two-day
Subtitles
It's the third day of school. Hey, it's span people. I don't beat around the bush. You're coolest. Shit. What's your name?
Call me nicole. Hey, I'm jacka. So how do you know chrispin?
Who's chrispin that guy you were just talking to oh guitar pick necklace
Both days. I've been here. He's talking to me. I have no idea who he is all of four and five
Okay, so a kind of work to be burned down a convenience store. But yeah, he's nice
I was playing resident evil five the other day because it was like, I don't know if it was free or really like um
She um playstation video games and I was like this feels weird and one i'm getting really emotional
Oh, that's tragic. He lives at home still. Yeah, I don't even go to this school surfing
She doesn't even go here to live off or something
No, he's not gay. I also like me
And then can he like
And get a boyfriend to live off fucked up. I asked that exact same question and all he said was bottoms
Don't top. I don't know what really works. Oh, so he's like really in the video games
Is he one of those guys that like end up on the news for messaging kids last night?
He begged a 15 year old for naked pictures. Oh my god. He's that guy. Can we report our brother?
Uh, we'll see hey, I'd love to hang around more, but I gotta get to class. Where are you headed to?
Oh fuck no
Oh
Okay, we're going to photography
So to not make the intro to beginners photography too long
I'll simplify it by saying I'll have your shots looking superior by the end of this year
Oh superior, I get it now our class all these kids are annoyingly quirky
So nice of you to join us young lady
You sound way too happy to be actually happy. Oh my god
To make up for your tardiness. Perhaps you could help me out in the dark room. I don't like that
I don't want to go to the dark room
Make the teachers stop hitting on me
Skip because he asked me to do manual labor. Fuck you
Fuck i'm not going to photography class. I know you what's up
Why this is the girl's why the fuck are you in the girl's bathroom? No way. So what brings you here?
I'm sorry. I just really liked how you said that really not. No way. So what brings you here?
Because I've done like
Pissing all by yourself. No way
That's so crazy, bro. Because I've actually had people
Like come
Because I I get like sometimes I just don't
Give a fuck about what my co-workers say to me because a lot of them are younger than me
So I'll be like, oh my god this like guy texted me. I'm like, no really that's so crazy. Like let's say fucking way
Oh
Oh my god bring a girl to the girl's bathroom. I got a piss skipping
Duh now get out. Oh, come on. Wait. What class you cutting?
Photography the teacher tried making me do shit for free and I am not about that
Photography. Oh me too crazy
Crazy
If I can't avoid you great
You're a cool girl. You know that
Am I gonna fuck christmas? What?
I just like you, you know, dude get in line. Nobody knows how to
Honestly true. Everybody's like praying on her. Investigate apple of me
You have a lot of you know, she was replaced with a clone, right?
Conversations I listen to a lot of deep bands so I can never find a girl that can keep up with me in that department
did
You just threw that deep bands thing in there with no context. Come on. Can I at least know your name?
Is you wearing a warp shower shirt? Hi, nicole. You want to have a sit down with me? You know talk in the girl's bathroom
Should I talk to chrispin or should I not talk to chrispin? Should I just like tell chrispin to fuck off again?
I
Explained why she looks so young in the current day. Yeah, I'm telling she was replaced with a lookalike
Brutal reveal. No, I forget her name is
Don't talk to him
Tell him that off. I mean he waited for you
I'll put it to a vote. I'll put it to a vote
Talk to chrispin
I'm gonna get some more tea real quick like
I don't want to stop from this. I'll do it. Do it. Do it now.
I always don't. I don't want to get claimed
Why was he taken a while?
Hi booby. Hi, it's your boy. What's up?
Hello, how do you do it?
Who'd you make that for all you two folks? We call him Bayman
I also call him Mr. Titties because he has a big power show with boobs. He'll probably see it on the cat ham
Hi, hi cat. Oh, you're so snuggly
Chris, Bea and Rayla
Wait, let me walk over and see what you guys are talking about
Okay, everybody's so far saying no, it's 50-50. Are you serious? Okay
Never talk to the dude hangs around in girls toilets. What do you mean?
You want to talk to a dude that hangs around in girls toilets? You just, you know, try to be friends
Oh, your boyfriend can't let you go friends
I
Love this teapot so fucking much you guys don't have any idea
Best thing ever
Teas of microwaving it
And my British fans don't hate me as much
You get like little coasters
You can actually hear all of that. Well, yeah, because my house is small and it's an open concept apartment
My kitchen is literally like 10 feet away
Wait, did you I usually microwave tea but some lovely uh, subby Wubby some lovely member of the harem um got me a
teapot off my throne
Because they're like stop and I was like, all right
Okay
Okay, wait, I walked away. It was no and I come back and it's yes
You want me to humor him?
All right
All right, some Brit some Brit
You see the ASMR when Nicole who's he paws support over if he he interests his voice like what?
I'm a poor roommate having to listen to she be making
Uh, she beneath audio is great
Yes guidance counselor, let's talk it up. Hey, come on. No need for the jokes splitting hairs in the pool
Oh, yeah, I'm gentle. I don't know what jealous, but
It's because I'm American face and stuff
Although my mom like I had a girl having to cut all the entire time because my mom really likes tea
My mom is like very British despite not being British although we are of English
So my mom is English
She's like I want to be English person
In a good way people don't understand me like this girl
She can't do a first act though a pop punk and was like I thought punk was anti-pop like she didn't understand
I would have told you the same thing pop punks for boring suburban kids
I used to love listening to pop goes punk like I feel like no one at my favorite cover is boyfriends
By issues when they covered just a fever
I don't know. There's got to be more out there
Or a lollipop by a single thing. I can't handle the conversation
You're English. It's not huh. I'm a lot of things so much a conversation. I'm lily. I'm everything besides Asian
Well, anyway, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll let you go now, but oh, Nicole
Thanks for listening
You're a good friend and stuff bro. I just met you
You're a good person. I was forced to talk to
How is it 299 for a drop it like it's hot ringtone. It's bleep some bloops. Fuck out of here
Who is this drop it like this, huh?
Hey, thanks for listening and the women. How did he get my number weirdo? How'd he get my number?
Stop bitching you and hearing your voice your attitude just works for me idk
Yeah, idk is real romantic. I wanted to show you what you do to me
Show me what I don't see. Oh my god. All three inches of it. What the fuck? Why you said a dick pic?
Delete and forget about it with therapy or he made a mistake. Am I gonna spread his fucking nude?
Was he hard?
Oh a little little
Hey, what's up? It's your boy skinny penis
He made a mistake
Then again, he kind of just put himself out there like that
Send it to her three inches average. Oh
Oh, honey. Oh, baby girl
Oh, sweetie
Hey guys, what's going on here? Are we having fun? You hear the new drops
You don't even know bro. You don't even know I would have hold on after school time was pause. I'm gonna put them on blast
There's one dude who just begs in my maros for me to insult his tiny pee pee and
I'm like, dude
First of all, where is it second of all fuck out of here
Oh
Sure, yeah, it wasn't long at all, right? Oh, suck see here, bro. What happened literally everyone at school see your micro penis
Wait, wait, did I did I spread it literally everyone? Oh, suck see here. Yeah, it wasn't yeah, I would have
Hey guys, what's going on? Send it to hers
Then again, he kind of just oh, so is she okay? We did spread it
Send it to her send it to her send it to him barely know him, but let's give it to him too
Why don't you spread it? Okay, what's going on here? We haven't fun. You hear the new drops at the cd shops
Oh, hey chrisbin. Yeah, I would have but my after school time was kind of short
Yeah, it wasn't long at all, right? Oh, suck see here, bro. What happened literally everyone at school see your micro penis
Why is the principal so hot like she looks like a new pop character
Crispin's been sending out pictures of his junk to every girl in school. That's not how I heard it
I thought it was just one girl and then she sent it to everyone
Who was it then? Tell me chrisbin gonna kill me
This is a the new girl nicole
Sexually harassing our new students. You're in big trouble. Mr. He thought she was gonna look like it was gonna defend her
Oh, fuck nicole. Call the teacher from honeybob. We need to talk about oh god
Not you too your principal called and told me there was a problem at school
A boy sent you some unsolicited pictures mom. This is gross. I'm not talking about it with you
You were forced to look at sexual imagery nicole the child psychologist say that can really stunt development
Every day I'm thankful the principal's fat titty. So like I never worked again
I didn't have any friends. I was a loser. So I never had to go through something like that
She views literally jesse who knew pop. I'm apparently so I've been compared to her before
Especially just like it looks because we do look very similar. Um, I feel like she would wear my outfit
But like I've had like uh
classmates who receive that stuff
and
I like they were like, oh, I got this from this person and I'm like, what does that mean?
They're like, but you don't know what that is shows picture of me
Like this also, um, one of the girls and one of my classmates growing up her mom was a porn star
And we all found out in high school because
And I'm not fucking joking her boyfriend at the time found a video
Of the mom I'm born
And spread it to the school and she was gone like this and the girl is sweet too. She's sweet like her daughter
And she was gone for like a month. She did not show up
And then I remember
She told me or like told some girl that told me or whatever the fuck because I just like knew everything
People would just tell me stuff because I was quiet and I'm a good listener
and she told me uh
That oh and her mom is hot though. Like her mom was hot. Um, and she drove a really nice car
I like I didn't see the video, but I I saw like the mom like drop her off. Um
Yeah, Amy and chat
Amy's also going crazy with the rest of you. Um, and she
Said that she walked in at her parent and not her parents like her mom and some random guy and it was like
Her parents had had this agreement. I don't know the video. I never saw them. Why would I shit? I don't even remember the mom's name
That's fucked. I would never do that the hell but yeah, it's just like that's why I kind of feel bad for
Some kids growing up and like the only fans era where every girl
Excuse me is doing only fans especially like some like moms trying to make ends meet
Are their kids because then it just like gets spread to the kids
And it just saw I just feel bad for them
But then like I know why the moms are doing it because they're trying to you know
Make money to live, but then I'm like, oh
Honey needs to go to therapy that the little baby needs to go to therapy
Lisa's pay wall. Yeah
It's gonna do you sold images and we're gonna go to the machine friend. Yeah
Yeah, it's like some people it could be fun. Yeah, like one of my um
Uh close like church friends growing up
And I didn't know like a lot of the girls in my church were like leading double lives because I was a little good at mischievous and um
Her stuff got spread
and
She got excommunicated because of it and I was
Really heartbroken because she was like my closest friend because she was like a little bit normal
Um
And I never was able to talk to her again
I stumbled across her like her her page at one point
And seeing where she was at and I gave a little high but like yeah
Yeah, it was like like that shit ruins lives and like none of the the boys that spread it
um
Got in trouble only she did
Because they were like, oh you harlots
get got
And they like interrogated her deeply about like what she sent. So the fucking
pastors or freaks too
That's another reason I left
All over the goddamn place. This isn't about her. Oh, yeah, no, they're and they're still fine to this day guys
This was very serious
Uh
Exaggerate trauma with pity. Oh hell yeah
Mom I really don't know give me some pretty gifts mom. Oh sweetie. What happened? It's okay. You can tell me
You won't be mad. No, you didn't do anything wrong. Yeah, that's weird a lot of like a lot of shit happened around me
But never to me like I had a fairly normal childhood minus like having
religious stuff
like I wanted to school
Uh, what did I have to go program?
I did some like hobbies like my mom put me in extracurriculars like I did okay grades
You know, I went through depression like everybody and their mom does lately
um
Because the meadow ill in the way runs in my family
But then and then I'm just like now I'm here
And like got a job and you know and now I'm a vtuber
But like everything like but I heard a lot like again. I was a good listener. I was quiet
I was I was I was the one who knew shit. I had the receipts
Oh, he sent me the picture and just wouldn't stop texting me
Let me get mental a little boy
I was yeah, I was like an npc. You just like knew too much. I hope you're a vtuber. I know it's great
You're gonna take care of that tomorrow now. What else?
Well, the next day at school he was way too confident with me. He's just pinning me against the locker and
Licking my earlobes
Just sick. I know he told me I was his come here chat
It's all right
Oh, this is the hardest part of being a mom. I swear. I'm sorry. I'm a disappointment mom
I'd want a daughter who gets a's on math tests instead of d's to the face
Okay, is there any way I can make this better anything at all
Well, maybe some new I don't know. Why don't you bark bark for me?
Bark for me right now. What? How many?
A full wardrobe. Just to get me through to graduate. Can't you? No, sweetie. You can't shoot your whole life around over one user
I'm calling. Get rid of that man
Maj, remove him
And if they don't, I'm filing a lawsuit. We'll even move if we have to
Send him to the principal office as he wants. It's okay
You didn't do anything wrong. Now, where's that office number? Amy? You don't need to bark. Don't worry
Thank you mods. I salute you
Mom called again and threatened with a lawsuit. She forgot one crucial detail, though
I'm on the assisted income lunch plan. So they knew she couldn't afford a lawyer
Like six different alimony checks and they're all going to hey, so we just moved for this ending. So we're moving again
Sort of god, I can never be satisfied
Until it's too late
interesting
Oh my god, my cats are sprinting around my house. Holy shit
Hell yeah
You agreed to ruin this. What do you mean? Yeah, it was like a pretty normal ending, I suppose
I'm gonna get satisfied
I guess it was like an ending like okay. She's cool
I have to hear about you and you aren't even dead
Oh my god
I don't know where this one came from
Do you ever like figure out if you get all the endings? Do you ever figure out who's texting you?
No
Okay
Oh interesting, I bet it's like jacka or something like a really big plot twist god is texting me
God's like wow
Become very apparent
Or it's like megan final app time. Yeah, finally app time before we go see I see we're gonna rate into I see
Because I'm icy I see haters want to bite me
Every time I hear her name, I think of that song by suede
um
Actually, I like the piano we're gonna let it play in the background
That's lovely piano
You're about to learn who is texting you one of the roots. Oh really?
Oh, shit. How do you feel about this ball? This ball is pretty good. This ball is staying up
What did you guys who I see I see is my sweet baby girl my sweet
Put-and-pop pookie pie my she's my my gen mate
Part three you mean part two
She's my gen mate be alert. So please yeah in the description
below
Please check out the other girls. Also. I have merch
For those who have bought merch. Thank you. You're fucking bomb. It's so crazy to have my own merch
I can't wait to start myself in my own merch
Except I don't want to get recognized. So probably start myself
Struck myself my stuff around my house and show up for my cats
You're hemi gaki. What's hemi gaki mean?
Love unbunked vods. Yeah, and you're gonna get a second unbunked vod today. You're gonna get um, whatchamacallit Stanley parable
Oh
Princess gaki bruh. Oh, yes
It's you come a hemi gaki
You think don't worry about the boobs you think come a hemi gaki. I am a princess
I am the best princess
I'm brat princess you will obey me and everything I tell you to do
Like lick my toes bark for me puppy
Why you mean I'm I'm not
I'm not I'm a hag
I'm three thousand years old
Okay
I'm three thousand and fifty six
Mama's I'm bunny is scary
I don't know why I'm barking, but um bunnies don't really make noise besides like
Too bad you like older girls. Oh no
Save me from that one
See I I can look like a puppy dog when my ears my ears are floppy and this is my collar
Yeah, yeah
I'm getting real good. Can I tell you a secret?
Can I tell you a secret?
You're really stinky
Can my ears go up? No, I am a lot funny. I am floppy ears
Anyways, I don't know who that was. I just got possessed. That was so crazy. So weird. Um, how you guys doing?
Oh
I just showered uh, did you what was like headed shoulders, dude?
Head and shoulders three and one
I don't know. I got like
If you're a guy like have a skincare routine
Get some, you know, well get get a little, you know, well groomed. Don't be stinky
You know do some lotion get some body wash then separate that with hair and shampoo
shampoo and conditioner
Don't don't use the same thing for everything like that's that's such an ick for me
That's such an ick when guys do the
24 in one. Is this a manscape ad?
I've actually nicked my coochie with one of their razors. I do not recommend. I usually get, um
Male hygienic stuff because it's just cheaper because women's stuff is very expensive because that pink pink price tag
I've always been having 11 step facial routine. See she gets it
You want a high maintenance bf? Yeah, come on
come on guys
Hair um if you want to be my lover you got to get with this 11 step skincare routine
True remember when tallying go hair first then go below. Oh, you know, that's a good advice
I think what do I have at my I have okay. I do a toner
uh serum serum
Moisturizer eye cream
Face oil face spray how many is that seven? I'm looking at my hands in confusion
If you want to be my lover you gotta have good hygiene
If you smell real stinky, I will be real mean get the fuck out of my face
Don't even talk to me. Anyways, I'm gonna end stream. Let's go watch icy
You know pretty good. Maybe I should be like freestyle rapper
So we're having a smooth face
bars
All right, I'll see you guys. I'll also be an icy stream because I'm gonna probably nap before uh stanley parable
I'll see you guys
So
I don't know. I need to have like an outro or something. I thought we were the fuck